Robert Louis Stevenson: Living Life Through
Imagination
Robert Louis Stevenson holds a special place
in the hearts and minds of many readers.
He often served as an introduction to real,
grown-up books.
Stories like Kidnapped and Treasure Island
may be considered classics, but they're also
full of adventure and intrigue — the sort
of stories that make you wish you were one
of his characters, sailing the high seas,
looking for buried treasure, fighting to reclaim
your legacy.
His stories are undoubtedly all classic works
of literature, and while many are told against
the backdrop of very real events, like the
Jacobite rising of 1745, there's also something
about them that speaks to a sense of grand
imagination, a longing for adventure, and
a deep sense of justice.
It’s time to pull out your spyglass and
take a peek at the life of this 19th century
Scottish writer.
You'll find there's a reason he was so good
at telling some of the tallest tales imaginable,
setting them against epic, historical backdrops.
For much of his life, his world was only what
he could see -- or dream -- from his sickbed.
An ill child who lived through imagination
Childhood often lays the groundwork for a
lifetime, and for Robert Louis Stevenson,
that was definitely the case.
He was born on November 13, 1850, the only
child of middle-class parents.
His mother came from a family of high education,
growing up in a world of church ministers
and lawyers.
His father had a job that most people would
consider not only respectable, but pretty
cool: he was an engineer, and he was involved
in building numerous deep-sea lighthouses
along Scotland's coast.
For much of his childhood, the family lived
at 17 Heriot Row in Edinburgh, and it's a
place anyone with a healthy respect for Georgian
architecture would truly appreciate.
Built some time between 1802 and 1806, it
was still fairly new when the Stevenson's
only child roamed the halls; it's easy to
imagine a young boy running up and down the
stairs, jousting his way down the hallways,
staging adventures in the garden, perhaps
turning the giant enamel bath his father had
installed into a swath of ocean filled with
monstrous creatures.
Unfortunately, Stevenson's childhood was very
different.
When his parents welcomed him into the world,
he was a perfectly normal, healthy boy, but
it wasn't long before he started suffering
from severe respiratory problems.
Those problems would shape not only his childhood,
but the rest of his life.
Stevenson spent a lot of time during his formative
years fussed over by anxious parents and cared
for by a nurse who would end up having a major
impact on his adult life.
He wasn't — as one might expect — hunting
for buried treasure in the back garden, or
pretending to ride imaginary horses up and
down the streets of the city.
Instead, he spent much of his time swathed
in blankets and shawls, doted on by the adults
around him, learning that he was very fragile.
Historians never quite decided just what it
was he suffered from.
The original diagnosis was tuberculosis, but
today, it's suspected that modern medicine
would come up with a diagnosis of bronchiectasis,
which is a series of continuous infections
resulting from damage done to the lining of
the bronchial tubes — a condition often
said to be made worse by the presence of dust
and air particles, and often starting with
a childhood illness.
If that's the case, there's a sad addendum
to his sickly childhood: his well-meaning
caregivers were always afraid of drafts making
him ill, so the windows in the home were always
closed.
Would some fresh air have made a difference?
It's impossible to say.
What we do know is that Stevenson's childhood
nurse had a profound impact on him.
Her name was Alison Cunningham, but everyone
called her Cummy, and she lived with the household
for a full two decades.
By all accounts, she loved the young Stevenson
as if he were her own son, and in addition
to being a caregiver, she was also a story-teller.
True, Stevenson was often confined to his
home, or to the strictly regimented life of
a health spa, but only in the physical sense.
Cummy entertained her young charge with a
variety of tales.
Her firm Calvinist beliefs formed the backbone
of many of the stories she regaled him with,
but she also told tales of ghosts, ghouls,
and other supernatural spectres.
Nights were particularly difficult for Stevenson.
From a young age, he suffered from insomnia,
and was was often kept awake for all hours
by illness and feverish vision.
Frequently be lulled back to sleep by his
father, who would sit by his side and invent
conversations with imaginary people.
The conversation was always droll but always
soothing, sending the young boy drifting off
to sleep, escorted by made-up characters and
conversations plucked from thin air.
And sometimes, it was Cummy who filled Stevenson's
sleepless nights with stories, fueling his
nighttime delirium.
If you look at Stevenson’s childhood through
a more modern lens on parenting, and it's
easy to put some sort of blame on the shoulders
of his guardians.
He was also susceptible to nightmares, and
there's one school of thought that suggests
the mix of Cummy's religious doctrine, ghost
stories, and the fevers he frequently ran
fueled those nightmares and those sleepless
nights.
But it also fueled something else: his imagination,
and imagination isn't always kind.
Still, given that he started "writing" his
first work at the tender age of six — he
dictated a tale called "A History of Moses"
to his mother — it's safe to say that from
a very young age, he was enthralled by the
power of the story.
His caretaker must receive at least some of
the credit for this
It's been suggested, too, that Stevenson’s
illness didn't just inspire him, but magnified
his the ability to write.
As he grew older and more established, his
letters began to mention the phenomenon of
splitting into what he called "myself" and
"the other fellow."
It was, he said, a side effect of the high
fevers he so frequently suffered from, and
it'll sound familiar to anyone who's read
the tale of Jekyll and Hyde.
"Myself," he said, was his rational mind,
while "that other fellow" was the side of
him that held the darkness and the creativity.
For Stevenson, that wasn't scary.
He loved it, it drove him, and he believed
it helped him create the works we all still
love today.
Life as a writer?
You'd better have a back-up plan
With the benefit of hindsight, it seems like
a given that Stevenson was a natural writer.
But that belief wasn't always there, and his
parents certainly didn't want their only son
throwing his life away on what is often a
gamble of a career choice.
By the time he was a teenager, though, Stevenson
was confident that his future career path
would involve the written word.
His father, on the other hand, hoped he would
become an engineer -- the third such professional
in the family.
Resigned, Stevenson enrolled in the University
of Edinburgh to study engineering.
It was quickly clear that going to university
just wasn't for him, and instead of spending
his time attending lectures and pouring over
his studies, he was more interested in making
friends.
And here is where one of those strange coincidences
happen.
One day, as the story goes, Stevenson was
simply walking down a street in Edinburgh
when he bumped into another student.
They got to chatting and ended up heading
to the tavern for a few hours instead of going
to class.
The other student was JM Barrie, who would
go on to write Peter Pan.
Beyond his adventures in Neverland, Barrie
wrote of Stevenson that "Some men of letters,
not necessarily the greatest, have an indescribable
charm to which we give our hearts."
A backhanded compliment, maybe, but other
writers who met Stevenson at the same time
and over the course of his career were completely
taken with him.
Edmund Gosse would later describe their first
meeting in London like this: "As twilight
came on, I tore myself away, but Stevenson
walked with me across Hyde Park, and nearly
to my house.
He had an engagement, and so had I, but I
walked a mile or two back with him.
The fountains of talk had been unsealed, and
they drowned the conventions.
I came home dazzled with my new friend."
One of the things that constantly struck those
who met him was the contradictory duality
present with him.
Outwardly, he was incredibly frail.
At 5-foot-10, he weighed only 116 pounds when
he was 23 years old.
When he spoke, though, he could easily capture
the attention of a room.
So it wasn’t entirely surprising when, in
1871, he did what many people would be terrified
to do: he told his parents that he wasn't
going to follow in the family footsteps after
all.
Stevenson was going to be a writer.
Anyone who has ever dropped a bombshell like
that on their parents can probably imagine
how well that went over, but Stevenson’s
parents weren't completely opposed to the
idea.
They only insisted that Stevenson have a back-up
plan, so his parents asked him to study law,
just in case the writing thing didn't take
off like he thought it would.
He agreed, completing his law degree
in 1875.
Love comes when you least expect it
It
was just a
year after graduating from law school that
Stevenson's life would drastically change.
It started with his want for adventure; imagination
was wonderful, after all, but he wanted to
experience all the things he had dreamed about
as a child.
He first planned a canoe trip, beginning in
Antwerp and ending in the north of France.
Afterward, he headed off to a small town south
of Paris, called Grez-sur-Loing.
It wasn't a random choice: the town was a
favorite among the artistic and bohemian communities,
and Stevenson already had a cousin living
there, Robert Alan Mowbray.
But it was also here that he would meet the
love of his life.
Fanny Van De Grift Osbourne ended up in France
after a fairly epic story of her own.
When she was only 17 years old, she married
an American military officer named Samuel
Osbourne.
Following the American Civil War, he headed
off to seek his fortune in the silver mines
of Nevada.
He told his family his wife and daughter to
join him, and they did.
Fanny didn't like it the West at all.
The Indiana native bore two more children,
but her husband proved less than honorable.
Sick of his cheating and his prolonged, mysterious
disappearances, she packed up her children
and left Nevada for Belgium.
This, too, was 1875.
It was a time when most women wouldn't have
even considered such a thing, and the first
obstacle they faced showed just how different
times were.
She and her daughter had planned on studying
art in Antwerp, but were told that women were
not allowed to enroll in art schools.
They moved on to Paris, but when her youngest
son took ill and died, she retired to a small
town in the countryside with her remaining
children.
The town was, of course, the small artists'
community of Grez-sur-Loing, and that's where
she met Stevenson.
They had a lot working against them.
She was 11 years older than him; she had two
children already; technically, she was still
married to Osbourne.
Stevenson, meanwhile, was fresh out of law
school, had no job or career to speak of,
and was still trying to figure out just how
he was going to turn this whole writing thing
into a livelihood.
He had already written one book based on his
earlier canoe trip, but one book won't support
a family.
Stevenson courted Fanny for two years.
They enjoyed each other’s company, but the
presence of another man in her life eventually
forced Fanny to reconsider the one she’d
left behind.
She decided to return to California to give
her husband another chance.
Abandoned by the woman he loved, Stevenson
set out on another adventure — one that
would become the inspiration for his second
book, Travels with a Donkey in the Cevennes.
For 12 days, he hiked the Cevennes with the
help of a donkey who carried his baggage for
him; he covered 120 miles of difficult country,
which wasn't just ambitious -- it was outright
dangerous.
Not everyone was a fan of the book, particularly
because of the treatment of its titular character.
When Stevenson bought his donkey, he named
her Modestine, and by the time the 12 days
were over, her value had been cut in half.
Getting her to move along involved Stevenson
delivering regular blows, and one critic summed
up just how horrible it was, writing, "Raw
legs and bleeding skin do not move him in
the least."
The trip had been taken at least in part in
an attempt to heal a broken heart, but their
story wasn't over yet.
In 1879, Stevenson received a telegram from
California.
Fanny was sick, her husband hadn't changed,
and she regretted ever leaving Europe.
In a grand gesture that really is the stuff
of a classic romance novel, Stevenson hopped
on a ship in Glasgow and sailed for America.
After landing in New York, he took a train
all the way from the east coast to the west,
and by the time he reached her in Monterey,
California, the journey had taken a terrifying
toll on his already fragile health.
But for Fanny and her children, it seemed
worth every sacrifice.
By December of that 1879, she had formally
divorced Samuel Osbourne.
Less than six months later, she married Stevenson.
Those early months were filled with extreme
highs and lows.
Stevenson and his new bride stayed in Napa
Valley for a time, where he wrote The Silverado
Squatters.
But it was also there that he became seriously
ill, as he developed a new symptom: he began
to cough up blood.
Was it a death sentence… or did it make
life worth living?
Stevenson’s poor health never really rebounded
after the long trip from Scotland to California,
and for the remainder of his life, the little
family moved several times in an attempt to
find a climate more agreeable to his delicate
constitution.
The first stop was England, where they lived
until 1887 — save for the winters, which
were spent in the south of France.
Stevenson supported his family by writing
essays and bits of travel journalism, providing
readers with his thoughts on dogs, umbrellas,
and a litany of other common observations.
However, this time is more associated with
the publication of his major career highlights:
he wrote and published Treasure Island in
1883, plus The Strange Case of Dr. Jekyll
and Mr. Hyde, and Kidnapped, both in 1886.
Treasure Island, in particular, came from
a brilliant moment of inspiration.
The family was away on holiday, staying in
a small Scottish town, and the day was rainy
and dreary.
The story varies a bit — some say Stevenson
was the one to first draw the map of a mysterious
island, while his stepson, Lloyd, would later
claim it was he who drew it.
Either way, a map was drawn, and Stevenson
began to name points of interest: Spyglass
Hill, Skeleton Island… then, someone added
three red crosses and a title of Treasure
Island, and the foundation of one of the literary
world's most beloved pirate tales was formed.
And here's a little aside — the map included
in various editions of Treasure Island was
not the original.
That original map was lost, somewhere between
submitting it to the publisher and getting
the book printed.
While Stevenson did redraw the map himself,
he was reportedly never quite happy with it…
and the fact that the original map for Treasure
Island is actually lost is pretty darn appropriate.
In 1887, Stevenson’s father died; with no
real reason to stay in Britain any longer,
he and his family left — first for a year
in America, then to the South Pacific.
Eventually, they reached Samoa, where they
decided to stay, at least for a moment.
In Samoa, he not only wrote a lot — often
from the confines of a sickbed — but he
also became a treasured member of the community.
He immersed himself in local politics and
activism, and was even given the title of
Tusitala, or the teller of tales.
Originally, Samoa had just been another stop
on the itinerary, with no real intention of
staying there, but Stevenson gradually came
to the conclusion that the climate would be
good for his health.
With his mind made up, Stevenson bought a
300-acre estate and settled in to the place
that Steveson and Fanny considered to be their
first real home.
Sadly, it would also be their last.
Samoa’s Setting Sun
On the surface, their lives should have been
idyllic.
Locals and travellers — particularly those
who had made the journey to Samoa from Scotland
— were always welcome at the estate.
They celebrated everything from birthdays
to American Thanksgiving; food and songs were
more plentiful than the guests.
They had around 15 servants working to keep
the estate running, and Stevenson himself
found solace in working the land.
He took to gardening and weeding, in particular,
once writing, "Farming is amusing; literature,
save in results, is intolerably stupid.
[...] Nothing is so interesting as weeding."
There was an unhappy undercurrent, though.
Fanny aspired to be an artist of her own,
and when he told her that she had "the soul
of a peasant," she was extraordinarily offended.
Stevenson had meant it as a compliment — watching
gardeners and botanists work to plant and
cultivate the land had made him wonder if
writing was real work; physical labor, it
seemed to him, was a much more worthy endeavor.
But Fanny didn't take it that way, and the
artistic anxiety she had always struggled
with only got worse.
Fanny's very presence in Stevenson's life
continued to be controversial.
While Stevenson's parents had come to accept
her — his widowed mother lived with them
in Samoa — his friends did not.
They resented her for telling friends they
couldn't visit, and for inserting herself
in his work.
She long claimed that she was responsible
for the success of Jekyll and Hyde, claiming
that she'd insisted he completely rewrite
the first draft of the work.
While there was no love lost between Fanny
and Stevenson's friends, there's little doubt
that they truly loved each other.
But as the years at the estate in Samoa went
on, Fanny continued to struggle more and more
with a nervous illness that had plagued her
for years.
As for Stevenson, he did continue to write
while living at the island estate, but he
would never match the success of his earlier
work.
Most of his later publications were historical
works or travel essays, and when they didn’t
take off, he grew increasingly worried about
money.
That stress ratched up with the release of
one of his histories that detailed the fight
between colonial powers that were vying for
control of the island; when the book was published,
he began to worry that it was so controversial
that he could be deported.
Stevenson’s stress and health issues finally
hit critical mass on December 3, 1894.
He worked on a fiction project in the morning
and wrote some letters in the afternoon.
Later, he helped Fanny make some mayonnaise.
That's what he was doing when he collapsed
-- he was dead by the evening, likely of a
cerebral hemorrhage.
Robert Louis Stevenson was buried on the island,
and his grave is marked by a stone on which
is inscribed the epitaph he wrote for himself:
Under the wide and starry sky
Dig the grave and let me lie
Glad I did life and gladly die
And I laid me down with a will
This be the verse you grave for me
Here he lies where he longed to be
Home is the sailor home from the sea
And the hunter home from the hill
Fanny and her children only stayed on the
estate for a few months after his death, although
her ashes were buried beside him after her
passing in 1914.
When they were reunited, it was to a huge
celebration on Samoa, as they were laid to
rest in what has been called "the most inaccessible
grave in English letters."
It’s an appropriate description for the
final resting place of the man who wrote the
world's most famous, beloved tale of pirates
and buried treasure.